ONE WILLIAM ALONG WITH EMILY
COMPAGNO, DANA PERINO,
GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN A TRIUMPHANT
MOOD WHILE DEMOCRATS REELING
FROM THE FALLOUT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUSES.
>> I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
EVIL ON THAT SIDE.
THEY’VE GONE CRAZY.
THEY SHOULD EXPUNGE THE
IMPEACHMENT FROM THE HOUSE.
THEY SHOULD BECAUSE IT WAS A
HOAX.
A TOTAL POLITICAL HOAX.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A TERRIBLE
THING WHEN SHE RIPPED UP THE
SPEECH.
FIRST OF ALL, IT’S A LEGAL
DOCUMENT, YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED.
IT’S ILLEGAL WHAT SHE DID.
SHE BROKE THE LAW.
>> Juan: MOCKING THE DEMOCRATS
OVER HOW THE IOWA CAUCUSES WERE
HANDLED.
>> THEY COULDN’T EVEN TAKE A
SIMPLE TABULATION.
AND YET THEY ARE TELLING YOU HOW
TO RUN THE COUNTRY AND HOW TO
RUN HEALTH CARE.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHO WON.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU WHO WON, THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
THEY ACCOUNTED FOR EVERY SINGLE
VOTE.
AND IT WAS A LOT OF VOTES.
IT WAS A RECORD-SETTING NUMBER
OF VOTES.
TRUMP WON.
>> Juan: WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP
TRIES TO CAPITALIZE OFF THE IOWA
DEMOCRATS’ CHAOS, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS HEADING FOR
A BIG DIVIDE.
NATE SILVER IS GIVING
BERNIE SANDERS BERNIE SANDERS A
50/50 SHOT OF WINNING THE ENTIRE
GAME OF THE PARTY’S NOMINATION.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS ARE NOT HAPPY
ABOUT THAT INCLUDING
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> VOTE FOR THE PERSON YOU
BELIEVE CAN ACTUALLY WIN IN
NOVEMBER.
AND THE PERSON WHO YOU THINK AND
GOVERN YOUR COUNTRY.
BUT YOU HAVE GOT TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT YOU SAY.
AND WHAT YOU WILL SAY YOU ARE
GOING TO DO.
WE NEED TO REBUILD TRUST IN OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS AND IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND IF YOU PROMISE
THE MOON AND YOU CAN’T DELIVER
THE MOON, THAT’S GOING TO BE ONE
MORE INDICATOR OF HOW WE JUST
CAN’T TRUST EACH OTHER.
>> Dana: HONESTLY, THAT
DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE.
SORRY.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Juan: YOU DON’T THINK THAT
DOESN’T MAKE SENSE?
SHE DOESN’T LIKE BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Emily:EMILY
>> Dana: I’M TRYING TO BE
NICE.
I JUST...
>> Greg: DON’T BE NICE!
THIS ISN’T "FOX & FRIENDS."
>> Dana: I DON’T REALLY SEE
HER LANDING ANY POINT.
IT’S THE SAME THING YOU’VE BEEN
HEARING SINCE 2008.
WHEN SHE RAN AGAINST
BARACK OBAMA AND LOST IN THAT
PRIMARY.
WITH THE BERNIE SANDERS THING...
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE HAD SUCH A
BAD WEEK.
I READ ALL THE COVERAGE THIS
MORNING?
I WAS REALLY ENJOYING MYSELF BUT
DANA BROOKS FOR EXAMPLE IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WRITES, ARE
DEMOCRATS TRYING TO THROW
AWAY -- ARE DEMOCRATS GOING TO
THROW AWAY AN ELECTION?
YOU HAVE JAMES CARVILLE, DO
YOURSELF A FAVOR, GO THERE, READ
THE INTERVIEW HE DOES.
IT’S PRICELESS BUT WHAT HE SAID,
WE ARE IN A TERRIBLE STATE.
THEN YOU HAVE JONATHAN CHAIT --
>> Greg: AND HE SAID THE
F WORD.
>> Dana: I LIKE THAT.
AND JONATHAN CHAIT, WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN SUCH BAD SHAPE THAT
WE MIGHT LOOK BACK AT THIS WEEK
AND THINK IT WAS THE HIGH POINT
OF THE ELECTION.
IT’S NOT JUST THE REPUBLICANS
ARE SAYING THE DEMOCRATS ARE
HAVING A BAD WEEK, JONATHAN
CHAIT ALONG WITH BILL IMAGE,
THAT WAS EMBARRASSING IN IOWA ON
TUESDAY NIGHT.
I THINK AMERICA NEEDS A WEEKEND.
>> Greg: NO!
>> Dana: AMERICA NEEDS A
WEEKEND.
I NEED A WEEKEND.
>> Juan: THE PERSON WHO IS NOT
QUITE AS HAPPY AS YOU WOULD
THINK, DONALD TRUMP.
HE SAID HE WANTS NANCY NANCY PEL
EXPUNGE THE HOUSE.
PETE: I CAME ON THE SHOW TO
CHECK ON YOUR HEALTH, WE’LL
STILL BE TALKING ABOUT THE BEST
WEEK EVER.
REMEMBER MY SHOW?
ABSOLUTELY FOR THE PRESIDENT, HE
HAS HIS OWN STYLE AND WAY OF
SPIKING THE FOOTBALL BUT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE STATE OF THE
UNION, ACQUITTAL, 49% GALLUP
APPROVAL SINCE THIS WHOLE THING
STARTED, 94% G.O.P. APPROVAL,
97% OF PEOPLE ARE SATISFIED WITH
THEIR PERSONAL LIFE.
EXCEPT FOR GREG GUTFELD.
LIEUTENANT COLONEL DENMAN FIRED.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT THAT GUY
INSIDE YOUR WHITE HOUSE.
YOU RETURN TO THE DEMOCRATS AND
SAY YOU’VE GOT YOUR FORMER
NOMINEE CLAIMING THE NEED TO
NOMINATE SOMEONE WHO CAN WIN AND
YOU’VE GOT THE NEW FRONT RUNNER
IS THE MAYOR OF THE FOURTH
LARGEST TOWN IN.
THIS IS AS BAD OF A MOMENT
DEMOCRATS HAVE HAD AND WE ARE
TALKING ALL ABOUT IOWA?
LOOK AT MILWAUKEE WHERE THE TOP
AIDES OF THE CONVENTION HAS NOW
RESIGNED AND SAY WE CAN EVEN
HANDLE THE CONVENTION THAT’S
COMING IN HOW MANY MONTHS FROM
NOW?
IT’S A DISASTER.
>> Juan: LET ME JUST SAY THIS:
DO YOU THINK THINGS WILL CHANGE
WHEN THERE IS A DEMOCRAT
NOMINEE?
ALL HIS VINDICTIVE BEHAVIOR?
>> Greg: IT DOESN’T GO WITH
EVERYTHING YOU SAID.
A50% CHANCE THEY NOMINATE A
SOCIALIST WHO IS NOT EVEN A
DEMOCRAT AND THAT’S FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHICH IS
THE LAST PERSON THEY WANTED,
BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Juan: I THINK TRUMP WOULD
VERY MUCH LIKE TO FACE
BERNIE SANDERS.
ONE OF THE THINGS PUZZLING ME IS
A TRUMP SAYS, RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IS A HOAX, BUT IS
ANYONE CONCERNED THAT THE
RUSSIANS MIGHT BE INTERFERING
AND THEY MAY DO IT AGAIN?
I DON’T GET IT WHEN HE COMES OUT
AND SAYS SOMETHING TODAY.
LIKE NOTHING EVER HAPPENED,
NOTHING CHANGES.
>> NOTHING REALLY CHANGES, JUAN.
>> Dana: WHEN YOU PROMISE THE
MOON AND YOU CAN’T DELIVER,
THAT’S WHAT’S BEEN HAPPENING
THIS ENTIRE TIME.
>> Emily: WE TALK ABOUT THIS
ALL THE TIME.
THEY ARE PUSHING THE GOAL,
MOVING THE FOOTBALL, SAYING THAT
IT IS THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
RUSSIA, IMPEACHMENT, IT IS THIS.
NOW THEY’VE MESSED UP IOWA, THEY
MESSED UP THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED EVENT.
EVERYTHING THAT OCCURS, THEY
MAKE FOOLS OF THEMSELVES AND TO
ME THEY ARE LIKE ZOMBIES RUNNING
AROUND EATING EACH OTHER,
POINTING FINGERS, TRYING TO
DRIVE US INTO IT.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAVE THE IOWA
CONGRESSWOMAN SAYING TOM PEREZ,
YOU SHOULD RESIGN.
WE HAVE THE IOWA STATE DEMOCRATS
SAYING THAT THIS DEBACLE IS
THEIR FAULT.
EVERY PART OF THE WAY, THEY ARE
POINTING FINGERS AT EACH OTHER
OR POINTING FINGERS AT TRUMP
WITHOUT OFFERING ANY TYPE OF
SOLUTION.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO SHOW FOR IT
AS CITIZENS WHO BENEFITED NOT AT
ALL FROM THIS AND THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO SHOW FOR IT BECAUSE
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO REVEAL
THEMSELVES AS INAPT LAUGHING
STOCKS.
>> Juan: WOW!
OKAY.
YOU HAD A STRONG REACTION TO
HILARY.
>> Greg: FIRST, I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IOWA.
SAYING THAT IT’S IN DISARRAY IS
LIKE SAYING THE GRAND CANYON IS
A HOLE.
THIS WAS THEIR FIRST DAY OF
SCHOOL AND THEY SHOWED UP
WEARING THEIR DAD’S GOLF BAG
WITH THEIR MOM’S WEDDING DRESS
OVER IT.
SOMETHING IS SERIOUSLY VOCALLY
WRONG ABOUT IT
WE DESERVE A VICTORY LAP BECAUSE
WE WERE PUT THROUGH SIX MONTHS
OF ALL OF THIS CRAP.
I YELLED AT THE PRODUCERS EVERY
DAY ABOUT THE HEARINGS.
>> Dana: YOU WANTED AN
APOLOGY.
>> Greg: THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD
BE APOLOGIZING TO OUR PRODUCERS.
IT’S LIKE WATCHING PEOPLE WITH
CONSTIPATION EATING BRAN.
JUST A BAD SCENE.
THE VICTORY LAP SHOULD NOT JUST
BE TRUMP BUT EVERYBODY WHO WAS
PUT THROUGH THE CHARADE.
THE BIG PICTURE, THE CONTRAST.
THE CONTRAST BETWEEN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHOSE NUMBERS
AND APPEAL ARE GROWING AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHOSE NUMBERS
ARE GOING DOWN.
YOU’VE GOT THREE METRICS WITH
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
JOBS WHICH ARE SOARING, WAGES
WHICH ARE GOING UP.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS’ COUNTER
OFFER?
DIVISION, IMPEACHMENT, RACE
BAITING, COUNCIL CULTURE, GOING
OUT AGAINST PEOPLE IN THEIR OWN
PARTY FOR SAYING THE WRONG THING
COMMITTING IDENTITY GROUPS
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SUPPOSED
TO BE ABOUT COMPASSION AND LOVE
AND THEY ARE EATING EACH OTHER’S
ALIVE.
LIZ WARREN BLAMING AMERICA FOR
HER TOXIC WORK CULTURE.
IT’S A JOKE!
THAT SOUTHERNER DUDE YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT, CARVILLE WAS SO
RIGHT.
>> Dana: THERE IS NO MERCY
RULE IN POLITICS.
WHEN YOU ASK, ARE THE THINGS
GOING TO CHANGE WHEN YOU’RE THE
NOMINEE, IF YOU ARE WHEN YOU
WANT TO KEEP WINNING.
>> Juan: WAIT A MINUTE!
DO YOU KNOW WHO IS WINNING?
BERNIE SANDERS.
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
JOE BIDEN ALL BEAT TRUMP RIGHT
NOW.
>> Greg: JOE BIDEN IS WINNING?
>> Juan: THIS IS WHAT I WAS
SAYING TO DANA.
ONCE YOU GET A NOMINEE, THIS
DYNAMIC SHIFT IN ALL THESE
PEOPLE IF THEY WERE THE NOMINEE
RIGHT NOW WOULD BE TO
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Dana: WE CANNOT IGNORE THAT
COURSE CASE
COURT CASE.
THE FEDERAL COURT OF APPEALS
RULED IN TRUMP SAVER AND SAID,
HEY, DEMOCRATS, LAWMAKERS, YOU
CANNOT SUE THE PRESIDENT OVER
THE EMOLUMENTS CLAUSE
>> Dana: THEY DON’T NEED A
WEEKEND, THEY NEED A DRINK.
>> Greg: I WANTED TO KEEP